i'm about to sit and watch picard series
2 episode 1 the stargazer
a little bit worried about this
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv
movie channel
[Music]
so yes i'm about to sit and watch the
episode this is going to be a bit
different so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to watch the episode
and i'm going to pause every so often
and i'm going to tell you what i
generally think so you're going to get
my instance there and then opinion
i am a little nervous about this like i
say mainly because picard series 1 was a
massive disappointment
started good
actually i watched it again recently it
didn't even start that good it was a bit
boring from straight off the bat but you
kind of expect that with a new series
because there's a lot of story to tell
so i kind of gave it a bit of a you know
gave it gave it a bit of rope you know i
didn't i didn't judge it too quickly
um
i loved a few little things like data's
return and stuff i got quite excited
about that
but i hated the way it ended now even
though i might have been a bit bored by
large chunks of the series first time
around
the end actually made me angry turning
and
picard becoming an android made me angry
the ships that turned up at the end
commanded by riker made me angry and
they threw it together bad cgi and just
copy and paste
where was starfleet in that entire
series that made me angry and when
starfleet did turn up they look crap so
yeah i didn't like picard series 1. so
basically there's a lot riding on picard
series 2.
for me at the moment they're spitting on
star trek
particularly the next generation
and i and i don't like it
but there but from a lot of the adverts
i've seen it looks like they might have
actually listened to fans while they
were producing this and they might have
fixed some of the problems i don't like
about it for example the starships and
the federation and the way they they
appear
so
let's get stuck into it
let's hit the play button
and i'll tell you exactly what i think
as we go along okay the opening sequence
is quite exciting isn't it
the um so basically it looks like the
there are going to be spoilers by the
way so i'm hoping you'll watch this with
me and then tell me what you think in
the comments but it looks like i think
that's the ball queen aboard the bridge
of a starship
um
obviously there's laser fires going
everywhere phase of fire going
everywhere they've gone back to the um
they've still got those phases with it
looks like a little like little p
shooting out of a thing rather than
which i loved from the original series
but never mind um
and then obviously there's you have the
voice we don't know if that's in
picard's head or not but there's some
sort of being on the bridge that's
trying to take over tentacles going
crazy um yeah very exciting very
action-packed open
i would say though that um a lot of star
trek at the moment is very action-packed
doesn't mean it's good so obviously this
series is going to be a continuation of
the exploration of who picard is
why he became the captain why he became
the loner that he is
obviously we've just seen his mother
yvette picard quite an annoying english
accent i'm not gonna lie
and it looks like something really bad
happened here which might be a trauma
that then goes on to explain the
psychology of jean-luc picard now i find
that really interesting
but i hope it doesn't suck too much of
the fun out of the show
the federation uss avalon thank god a
star fleet vessel actually looks like a
starfleet vessel
excellent spatial anomaly bit of mystery
let's see how we get on
in previous star trek iterations when
we've seen starfleet come academy
basically at san francisco it looks like
san francisco but with just a bit more
added sort of a bit more futuristic
the starfleet academy they have in this
is
dramatically different to i think what
we've seen in the past it's it's almost
unrecognizable as san francisco other
than the golden gate bridge
it's very much a different design to
what we've seen in the past
um a design though i don't particularly
hate i think it's actually pretty cool
looking
arias was one of my favorite characters
so i am actually very happy that sandero
cabrera is back for this series i love
that he is the captain of what looks
like the stargazer at this point because
i saw the uh diagram behind her on the
turbo lift and it definitely had four
nacelles
um so very excited about this i love how
he is sat on the bridge smoking a big
ass cigar um as you would expect nothing
better from rios uss stargazer is a
stunning looking ship i really wish they
hadn't teased it in the uh in the last
advert so that we we knew that would
have had so much more impact if we
hadn't have known
um the way they set that whole scene up
and then but but we already knew it was
the stargazer so that's a shame but hey
it's a good looking ship and again thank
god they actually listen and they've
learned their lesson from the first
series of picard and they've actually
got starfleet in this
for one but also then the starfleet
ships are actually starfleet ships they
actually look like something we would
recognize
great looking ship really happy about
that i should say as well the uniforms
they're really good
and they're a little bit of a blend
definitely from the tng there's
definitely a feel of the tng uniform in
there there's a little bit of a feel of
the ds9 uniform in there
um
i hate the uniforms from discovery i
think they're awful this is a nice blend
of like say two or three different
styles from the original the good star
treks um yeah the uniforms spot on
really like them that's stupid
guyana's just said that she's aging
she's because she's chosen to age she's
trying to keep up eloreans can age very
long and slowly if they want to but
she's chosen not to
they're also ignoring the cards and
android why don't they just ignore that
guidance looks older
noise when they they sort of force
explanations in like that unnecessarily
though they could have just ignored it
but yeah okay
so everybody's on the stuff there's a
very good and this thing about the
article 15 and this
entity basically pleading for help from
picard
very interesting setup
i cannot help though but think that the
green glow from this
um
subspace anomaly looks awfully borgy
so um let's see if that's just an
accident it's just a pretty green color
or is it purposefully
borg like
okay the ball coming through it's
actually pretty cool and it's not
traditional cube it's something else but
then the fleet arriving ready to take on
the borg encounter
but then the fleet arriving ready to
take on the borg is very cool we're
seeing a mix of lots of different ships
i can see what looks like a sovereign
class obviously this got the excelsior
massively refit version of the excelsior
but it looks completely different cells
etc but as a star trek fan i love the
starships i am a massive geek for the
different starships
so that is actually genuinely exciting
so far
i'm actually thinking that they've
listened to the fans they have fixed
some of the massive problems i mentioned
at the beginning
and this is genuinely
an exciting opener to this new series
it's a bit of a question since voyager
of actually how much damage did voyager
do to the borg species
we
kind of think that that the the damage
voyager did might have been irreparable
but we seem to have just had an answer
for that
seven and nine just said that the
borguino is a shadow of its former self
it's
basically been destroyed um that they
are they're a hovel and technologically
so it looks like the borg
at the end of voyager maybe
was virtually defeated
now that's interesting so is the borg
here now an opportunity or a threat
a very interesting story like now i
don't like the idea that the board of
beethoven because i think the borg were
the perfect bad guy the borg in a
weakened state
that's interesting
and what do they say about um an injured
animal if it's cornered
that's when it's it's most dangerous
so
there's a lot of riding on that episode
of star trek i was generally starting to
think about moving away from star trek
if that had been bad i don't think i'd
ever watch star trek again
but it was brilliant
so
star trek might actually be back
i didn't just enjoy that episode of star
trek that might be
the best 50 minutes or 55 minutes of
star trek that's been made for about 10
years
or 15 years
that's not just a great episode of star
trek that might be the best episode of
star trek this made since voyager ended
i absolutely loved it i loved that the
federation was back in it i loved that
the storyline was genuinely actually
gripping when the borg attacked in the
last few minutes of him i was genuinely
at the edge of my seat i forgot to
record a couple of things i could have
mentioned because i was enjoying it so
much
picard series 2 genuinely had a lot to
live up to mainly because of the
failings of picard series one but also
just because of the fans and how much we
loved the next generation and how
you know and even though this is a
different series it's always going to be
connected to it i'm a little bit
concerned
so the borg attack
picard has to destroy the fleet
and then
el capitan
we realize the time has changed he's at
the end of the road not taken so this is
the end of a different timeline
i'm a bit concerned about where the
series is now gonna go i'm hoping this
hasn't started with a massive bang and
it's gonna now deflate into a nonsense
like it did in the first series
i imagine now what picard is going to
have to do is go around and try to pull
the gang together because obviously rios
and so on are going to be in different
parts of the galaxy now and we're going
to have to try to find out where seven
is and so on and he's going to try
picard is probably going to try to bring
them back together to defeat this
upcoming enemy and the borg's return
i'm hoping they don't ruin that but from
what i've seen in the adverts i i think
we've got some fun episodes ahead
so what is my final conclusion
star trek is back
picard
series 2 episode 1 is that good
it's the best bit of star trek i've seen
in a very very very long time
it's pulled me back from the edge
because i was genuinely
genuinely worried about watching this
episode of star trek
i was honestly thinking that i would
probably never watch star trek again
but now i'm excited to watch the next
episode
i love as well that they're streaming
this an episode every friday so i've now
got a week to think about this and to
look forward to it lots of other
episodes i'd be binge watching it now
and i think it takes a lot away from
that i really like that they're gonna do
an episode a week
so
i probably won't do i'm not gonna do a
video like this every week looking at
the episodes i probably might talk about
it again at the end but
but i'm really really excited about it
and i'm really really happy they didn't
mess up at very least the first episode
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
hit all those nice buttons late up like
and et cetera
and you can become a fully fully
sidetracker if you would like hit the
join button please guys stay safe
watch star trek
and i'll see
wow